By unstructured we mean data arrives in lots of different formats.
For example, a bank might have list of your credit card
and account transactions. They may also have scans of checks, records
with customer service interactions. Maybe even recordings of those phone calls.
All that data in a variety of different formats can be
hard to store and reconcile in a traditional system. And this
brings us back to volume. You want to store that data
in its original format so you're not throwing any information away.
That way you can then process the data later in
different ways. For instance, if we transcribe a call center
conversation into text we have what people said to customer
service representatives. But if we had the actual recording as well
then later we might develop software which can interpret the
tone of voice the customer uses. And that might lead to
a very different interpretation of the data. And the nice
things about Hadoop is that it doesn't care what format your
data comes in. Unlike a traditional database, you can store the
data in its raw format and manipulate it and reformat it later.